it's time now for one more thing and
Dana goes first okay I have an important
announcement and a great announcement
Fox Corporation has donated a million
dollars to the American Red Cross to
support its efforts in a supporting
hurricane in relief the Red Cross is on
the ground they're providing Aid and
resources including shelter meals
medical supplies and more for people
who've been impacted by the storm foxes
also double matching employee donations
to Red Cross Hurricane Relief efforts
including Ian and Fiona our thoughts are
with our Tampa and Orlando station teams
they've gone through a lot and other Fox
employees in the area and everyone
affected by the storm thank you to all
our Fox Weather Fox News Channel and Fox
TV station teams across the country who
are covering this disasters how viewers
can help if you would like to join in
Fox's efforts is join this website or
visit this website
redcross.org
Fox forward we'll have that there on the
screen for you join fox in supporting
the Red Cross relief efforts and help
people affected by Hurricane Ian there's
going to be a lot of need so you can
donate at redcross.org fox4 hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else